police officers today often face
criticism for the way they interact with
people they are working to protect but a
team of deputy sheriff's and prosecutors
in Utah's receiving praise for going
above and beyond to save a woman's life
for tomorrow's 48 hours Erin Moriarty
shows us how officers solved one crime
and possibly prevented something even
worse my necks bleeding I need help
quick what happened I tried to commit
suicide please help me just before
midnight on July 23rd 2013 deputy
sheriff Jason Sorenson responding to an
attempted suicide found 22 year old
Tiffany Meade in her car it was a really
severe wound tell me where it was it was
straight across her neck all the way
across in the car seat was her
two-year-old son her husband Chris
Ertman was pacing the sidewalk he had no
shirt on I noticed he had blood all over
his hands by the time lead detective Bob
Thomson arrived Tiffany had already been
rushed to the hospital but before she
left she changed her story it was her
husband who attacked her the blood all
over the car was just it was
unbelievable I'm looking at this and I'm
like there's no way that somebody's
gonna be able to survive this do you
know whether it's a attempted suicide an
actual suicide attempted murder or a
murder I have no idea
police detained Chris Hartman who told
Thompson that he and his wife were
divorcing they had met at a secluded
park earlier so he could give Tiffany a
child-support check
you put a knife to her throat okay was
he concerned about his his estranged
wife no he didn't ask once how she was
doing and he never has to wear his child
was and what's going through your head
that he did this Herrmann was arrested
and charged with attempted murder
attempted because somehow Tiffany Meade
survived when you realize that you're
okay did you think then Chris is gonna
be charged with attempted murder I hoped
he would I thought he would all I
thought was this is gonna be over it
didn't end there
what's your fear he'll try it again did
you ever expect the case to take you
where it did no not in a million years
and Aaron is here with us now and so
police and prosecutors have their
questions and doubted the husband's
story why were they so concerned that
that a jury wouldn't find him guilty of
it well I mean this is a classic
domestic violence case this is why we
did it but very difficult to figure out
who really is the abuser once you figure
it out how do you prevent it from
escalating into murder it was a he-said
she-said and they were worried that they
couldn't actually once they were
convinced he did it actually convict him
of attempted murder because he's the
husband he allowed her to call 9-1-1 he
gave her a shirt so was he really trying
to kill her or just scare her I've never
seen a 48 hours where there wasn't a
murder I know this is a very different
case of preventing a far worse good all
these ain't questions will be answered
when they watch this weekend Thank You
Aaron and you can see Aaron's full
report don't scream tomorrow night on 48
hours that airs at 10:00 9:00 central
right here on CBS